I think we fired him two days in we paid  a Headhunter 140 Grand something like  that to head hunt a CTO for us wow jeez  just wasn't worth it we could tell right  away he was late to three meetings on  the first day and he said he couldn't  figure out how to use zoom and I was  like you're CTO could you not figure out  how to use him so we're like cool like  I'm sure you have a story we I just  don't care you know what I mean like at  this level you know this guy's probably  500 000 on your employee you're expected  to bring it if you can't do simple  things right then you're not going to do  the great things right to be fair I  haven't fired many Layla has done the  majority of the fire  because most the team rolls into